well the German government is drafting
new plans to smooth the entry process
for foreign skilled workers it's a move
that companies say is long overdue the
country's aging Workforce is a growing
liability while positions in I.T and
software development for example are
becoming notoriously hard to fill more
companies are now looking abroad for
help
one year ago ashai Murray came from
India to Germany and state language is
the main barrier but if we compare it
from other countries then I find the
country's code peoples are good the only
thing is this German thing the language
and you have to learn in the starting I
was thinking it was very very easy in
three to six months I will be
comfortable to speak in German it's not
an easy thing it take years
this man helped him Chennai doctor knows
both cultures he came to Germany decades
ago as a mechanical engineer he turned
his experience into a business and now
finds Indian Specialists like archai for
German companies they pay up to five
figure sums in commission for her
service as they can't find enough
suitable applicants in Germany and for
foreign software Developers for example
from Asia Germany is very attractive
ashai Moreno works at this startup
programming online stores for the boss
it's important that he can communicate
with his employees face to face
the reason why we bring our employees to
Germany they work alongside the German
software developers it's very important
for us to discuss everything as a team
team
there are more and more Indians coming
to work in Germany like ashaimore
Europe has a particularly good
reputation among Indians and fresh
graduates are more than plentiful
[Music]
I'm joined Now by Nicole burtner she's
co-founder and CEO of mirantic's labs as
a tech consultancy here in Berlin Nicole
Germany likes to tout its Tech startup
scenes especially here in Berlin how
critical are foreign workers to the tech
scene
highly reliable on Talent right that's
basically the main asset we put into it
and so the dependency is very high
and we need to be able as a German
textiles to attract foreign Talent here
and this relies on on different uh
different pillars right one of it is can
we create the conditions here that make
it very attractive for foreign workers
to come here and especially in the
startup scene this is something to do
with also being able to um to offer
equity and share compensation which is
still an issue and the other thing is
um just the barriers of finding
basically of getting access to the labor
market and the visa application process
Etc and making that as efficient as
possible
are you optimistic about what you're
hearing so far that this government
wants to do something I know right now
it's sort of a vague what they're
offering they're still drafting the law
but with what you're hearing what do you
see
I think um I got good I think good
intentions are good and I I are great
and are good are a good start
um but the German startup scene has been
asking for concrete measures and steps
for a long time now and we we're really
ready to see some action so um
optimistic that the intentions are
really good and um now very impatient to
see the first tangible results and if we
can see them early next year then I
think we will all be very happy
what would help the most in your opinion
most for startups
can be indeed some sort of equity
um uh remuneration right the problem
there is that startups um usually offer
employees employee shares and these are
taxed on the
um German uh tax regulation without
there being actual cash flows so people
would have to take on a credit to
basically pay the taxes on the the
shares they received which could go to
zero and we've seen this in recent
crisis
um so that would help enormously yeah
do you expect uh do you expect anything
to change within the scene itself given
where things are economically the fact
that uh mini tech companies are
struggling right now could it sort of
put the brakes on any attempts to make a
change right now
I hope not because if we look at the
global developments and we've seen um
unfortunately some of the big Tech
players that are globally known making
considerable and significant layoffs
this is the time to have the optimal
conditions for a talent to come to
Germany I think this is the opportunity
to season that's something that the
German startup association with Aesop
asset has basically been trying to push
for a long time and this is the time for
Action not for complacency all right
Nick Nicole builtner with marantex labs
in Berlin thank you very much
thank you